all right here now with more senior
counselor to president Trump kellyanne
Conway former Arkansas Governor Mike
Huckabee and Fox News contributor Arie
Fleischer you know you look at Kathy
hokel for example and then you look at
the statistics the murder rate the crime
rate the arson rate the burglary rate
and what part of what's happening is in
her state is she not understanding
kellyanne
her blender on the debate stage was akin
to Terry McAuliffe a year ago when he
said I'm going to make sure parents
don't have a say in their child's
education and he lost and this is uh for
Kathy hokel to not realize that not only
is reality reality we see it's an
occupational hazard to use the subway we
see that people are walking down the
street being randomly assaulted and
worse but also when it comes to Crime
perception is reality if the people of
New York don't feel safe and so many of
them are telling us they don't feel safe
that's enough for a governor to take
action but Lee zeldens run a masterful
campaign by putting crime front and
center and Public Safety and of course
the Democrats cannot walk back defund
the police those are the three most
poisonous words said by a political
party in quite some time Sean they can't
walk it back and let me say this it's
not just in New York and it's not just
in our major cities which are run by
democrats where the rates of crime are
going up it really is everywhere if
people feel insecure and unsafe if this
election is about everyday affordability
but it's also about physical security
border security national security health
security Economic Security if it's about
all of that then of course that's going
to help the party that is willing to go
out there and say no cashless bail we we
are here to punish criminals not to
punish the victims and people right now
in New York we just released a poll
where hokels only up one point both she
and Lee zeldin are 46 45 under 50
percent and he's really closing the Gap
because he has put crime front and
center but let's also not forget Sean
that unfortunately the zeldon family
knows crime very personally he was
attacked on the stage by a crazy person
with a weapon and then his two teenage
daughters were home doing their homework
and somebody was on his porch so this is
very personal to many folks 1994 top two
issues crime in the economy we had the
contract with America but now those two
issues are so much more personal and
front and center and you have an entire
Democratic party telling the country
don't believe what you see believe what
I say that's why voters are rejecting
that you know know Governor Huckabee you
look at things their economic policies
caused the 40-year high of inflation
their decision not to produce energy
domestically that has caused the price
of gasoline to soar as high as it is and
by the way wait till people get their
heating bills this winter
they went with open borders and
abandoned the policies of Donald Trump
that were working they're the ones that
want a woke education versus you know
the old-fashioned Reading Writing math
and history education they're the ones
that want defund dismantle and no bail
loss they have made decisions and the
consequences are now evident to
everybody in eight days the American
people get to vote on whether they like
these policies or don't like these
policies are you better off than you
were what 20 months ago 21 months ago I
think the answer is overwhelmingly no I
don't think they have anything
successful to run on and I don't see a
lot of success for them in this midterm
election
I think what you just said is exactly
right I think it's interesting that
their strategy right now is to bring
Obama out of mothballs but you know I'm
going to say something that you'll
probably disagree with Sean but I kind
of find it entertaining that Obama is
back on this stage now he's blowing
smoke out of both nostrils both ears and
the rest of the parts of his body and
he's telling a bunch of stuff that isn't
true like we're going to kill Social
Security and Medicare total nonsense but
I will say this it was kind of
entertaining to watch him because at
least he's somewhat funny and he can put
a whole sentence together and if you
look across the Democrat Spectrum
they've got a bunch of candidates that's
a pretty high bar he could actually put
a sentence together that's an amazing
accomplishment
and Sean when he's finished with his
speech he doesn't shake hands with the
ghost and he doesn't wander around the
stage trying to figure out how the heck
do I leave here so yeah if I were a
Democrat running I'd bring Obama in too
because it's all they got well I I don't
think that's bad advice or a pleasure
I'm not sure that that's going to
actually resonate look Americans if
we're going to break it down simply they
vote for peace they vote for Prosperity
I can't think of a single policy
Democrats and Joe Biden have implemented
that have benefited the American people
Ari Fleischer and to me it's that simple
it's that fundamental it's that basic
well and the other big fundamental
simple thing is the first midterm
election of a president's time in office
is always a course correction but this
year Sean it looks like it really is a
genuine wave and the way I look at it if
the Democrats had a perfect night they
could win 54 seats in the Senate they'd
have to knock off the Republicans in
Pennsylvania Ohio North Carolina and
Wisconsin I think Republicans can hold
all four of those seats now that's
pretty clear Republicans on a perfect
wave night could win 56 seats a week ago
I would have told you I don't see it
happening I don't see 56. now I can tell
you Sean I think there's about a 25
percent chance the wave is big enough
Republicans are going to end up with 56
seats that's New Hampshire that's
Georgia that's Nevada that's Arizona
Colorado and Washington State that's
what happens in a wave people wake up
shocked they just didn't see it coming
but in 2014 the second midterm of Obama
Republicans gained nine seats in the
Senate and no one saw that coming either
that's the thing about a way of election
you don't know it until you're soaked
you're under it and then the other party
is jubilant that is the possibility a
week from tomorrow that may be a pretty
happy guy uh a week from tomorrow if
that in fact happens Kalia what do you
see happening
oh it's going to be a big Republican
night I mean the Democrats aren't even
trying to solve the problem Sean they're
still arguing with the public about what
the problems are but I think the Obama
question is a really important one
vintage Obama was about Hope and change
but now he's out on a recovery and
rescue mission and he seems like he has
a boulder on his shoulder you know
peddling anger and lying about the
Republicans and may I just remind
everybody of Obama's record when he's
not on the ballot he's hardly the
mariana rivera the closer for these
midterm elections on his watch over
eight years the Democrats lost 12
Governor seats went from 28 to 16 they
lost nine Senate seats they lost 950
State Legislative seats and they lost
they went from 254 to 196 in the house
as 62 seats lost in the house so his
batting average if you will is not so
great when he's not on the ballot and
look I also think Obama's message is
tone deaf he did really good thing a
couple weeks ago on a podcast he said
hey stop talking about all these other
issues start talking about the economy
and then he goes out and he talks about
everything about the economy but I'm
with Ari on this I actually make another
prediction I don't think a single
Republican house or Senate incumbent
will lose there are a couple who are
embattled right now I think they'll be
dragged across the Finish Line in 2020
not a single house Republican incumbent
lost we turned 15 seats from Blue to Red
every one of those seats was taken by a
woman a veteran or a candidate of color
or some combination thereof we've
recruited such unbelievably diverse
candidates this time in the Republican
party and they're there and now they now
the party's investing in them six digit
investment in some of these
congressional districts Sean and
gentlemen where Biden carried those
districts by 20 points or so double
digits two short years we'll say the big
night I am impressed that you remembered
every single uh election uh Post Obama
and you're right he did have a terrible
track record uh in terms of uh people
that he endorsed over time Governor
Huckabee besides a huge victory that
we're both expecting in the great state
of Arkansas and a new governor there uh
what do you see happening a week from
tomorrow night
I think Ari has nailed it pretty well
and I want to make sure you understand I
didn't say Obama was effective I just
said he was entertaining there's a big
difference and I hope he continues to go
out there because he reminds everybody
that his policies and the things that he
did set up for the Republicans to take
power in 2016 and he may remind him that
maybe it's time to go back to the
Republicans yet again I think that's
what we're going to see and I would
second the motion to what Ari had to say
and I think he may be spot on I hope
Arias Ari if you're right you're going
to get the gold star you get the last
word
well the other thing about President
Obama because I just can't resist
remember he endorsed Hillary when he was
a sitting president and how did that
work out so he was at the height of his
power in incumbent in office he played
an active role campaigning for and
hoping for Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump won so you know endorsements
really don't mean much in the modern
political era what matters are the
fundamentals that's the economy that's
crime that's inflation and it's the wave
wave elections are rare but when they
hit they're big and that's what we're
heading into Sean I think we are too I
hope we're all right all right thank you
all hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else